My question to you, and I know you don't
believe Jesus is Messiah. Okay. Mhm. You
believe the servant is Israel. So,
Israel is exalted. Now, all I want you
to do is all I want you to do is tell me
with I know you don't believe in Jesus
Messiah. That's okay. Mhm. Why are
Christians [clears throat]
wrong for believing that Jesus, who's an
Israelite
and if the servant is Israel, the
nation, and the nation will be exalted
to status of God, why would you accuse
us of blasphemy in saying that this
Jesus, the Israelite, who would be part
of that servant, the nation Israel, has
been exalted to God status, when that's
what you find Isaiah 52:13 saying about
the servant. The servant to God status?
Yes, it does. It does not. It says high
and lifted up.
Do you want to Okay, hold on. Wait. I'm
going to give you what the Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Saying that because it says you will be
right, which is, you know, most people
pronounce it you know,
right?
This is not the It does not exactly say
to the status. This is not the same
status as God, right? It doesn't have to
be the same status as God. In fact, it
does not does not say anything.
>> It will be exalted on the same level of
a who does not say that. Okay. And the
thing is saying simply because these you
know, these two words are only ascribed
to God if they are, I'm not sure. I will
check for you. However,
it is not saying that this is the same
status as God. It's simply saying that
he shall be exalted and lifted up. These
is This is the literal meaning of those
two words. It simply means that this is
the the nation of Israel will be exalted
and lifted up. And listen, we are
described as you know,
you know, the light unto the Gentiles.
We are described you know, as the
consistently most highest nation, etc.
And you know, as an example for you
know, the non-Jews and for you know,
those who you know, the
you know, people who are
right, worshipers of the foreign
worshipers of stars, etc. are are to
follow.
Now, Now, you know, I let you just keep
speaking because you know, you're not
saying anything and I'm going to refute
you now, right?
That it is the same as status of God.
Are you ready now?
Yeah. Okay, because see, I just let you
cuz if I cut you off, you're going to
say, "Ah, I'm cutting you off." Okay,
you just told everyone
I want everyone to hear. You just said
it's not the same status of God. Now,
Mhm. I want you to read Isaiah 52:13 for
me one more time.
Behold, my servant shall prosper. He
shall be exalted and lifted up, and he
shall be very high. Okay, now very high.
Now, when it says exalted and what in
your translation cuz I don't know what
translation you're reading.
Exalted and lifted up. You Okay, now,
exalted and lifted up, right?
Mhm. Okay, now go to Isaiah 6:1.
It says the same words, I know. Same
words. Now, go do me a favor. Go now to
Isaiah 33:10.
And I'm going to read to you
what Rabbi Moshe Cohen ibn Crispin said
about Isaiah 52:13. I'm going to read
your own rabbi.
Mhm. Because I'm going to end with your
own rabbi to show that you're wrong, I'm
right because I I agree with the rabbi.
Okay, now Isaiah 33:10.
>> will arise, says the Lord. Now I will be
raised and I will be exalted. Okay, then
it Now, when it says I will be raised
and I will be exalted, is that that
they're not the same verb verbs used in
Isaiah 52:13?
Yes. Wait. Wait. So, wait. Your God is
going to be exalted and lifted up. Why
is he going to be exalted and lifted up?
And exalted and lifted up to where?
It is not necessarily literal. It's
essentially he will be
>> Whatever it is.
And it says I will be and then it says
you know, and right? Or
pronounce it. The thing is, right? This
doesn't necessarily say when it says you
know, I will be exalted and lifted up.
Essentially he's saying I will be
praised, right? I will be praised by the
nations.
>> And what makes him great?
His exalted status over creation, right?
Mhm. [clears throat] And that's
symbolized by what? What symbolizes his
status over the nations? His throne in
heaven. Say it again. Mhm. That's wrong.
Okay. Oh, but hold on. When the same
verbs are used of the servant, you don't
want me to believe he's been exalted to
the status of
God, even though those verbs are only
used of God and no one else besides the
servant,
but you still don't want me to believe
that because your rabbinic tradition
blinds you to allowing the scripture to
say what it says. Can you read Isaiah
57:15?
Yeah.
Isaiah 57:15.
Mhm.
Hold on. Let me see.
For the so high and exalted one who
dwells to eternity
and his name is holy with the lofty and
the holy ones I dwell. Slowly. Slowly,
man. I'm going too fast, dude. Calm
down. Read it again. With the lofty with
the lofty and holy ones I dwell and with
the crushed and humble in spirit to
revive the spirit as to revive the
spirit of the humble and to revive the
heart of the crushed. Okay, now your
translation translated it plural. I see
I can I see why you said the is bad.
Okay, it says for thus says the high
and lofty one. Can you confirm when it
says high and lofty one? Those are the
same two verbs
used in Isaiah 52:13?
Hold on. Let me see. Hold on. Read it
again. Isaiah 57:15. Wait, so who's the
high and lofty one?
Here? It's him. God. But in Isaiah
52:13, who's going to be the high and
lofty one?
Israel. Say it again.
Israel. So, wait. Hashem is high and
lofty
and his throne is high and lofty
and then Israel's going to be a high and
lofty and those words are only used of
God and his status and you still want to
convince me it doesn't mean that the
servant will be exalted to the status of
God. Yeah, I'm convinced, but now can I
read to you what the rabbi says? Now,
you don't have to agree with him. I
don't It's okay. Rabbi Moshe
>> show me Hold on. Hold on. Can I Can you
show me where Crispin says this as well?
Yeah, I'm going to show I'm right about
to read it. Rabbi Moshe Cohen ibn
Crispin, okay?
And I'll get you the quote. Okay, it's a
long quote. Are you okay with me reading
it?
Of course.
>> And I'll give you the link to my
article.
This is his exposition of Isaiah 52:13.
Says, "I will now proceed to my
exposition.
Behold, my servant shall have
understanding. From the prophet's saying
understanding, it may be seen that all
the lofty predicates which he assigns to
him have their source in this attribute.
In view of In view of In virtue of his
comprehensive intelligence, he will
attain an elevation above that even of
the most perfect men in the world. He
shall be high and exalted and lofty
exceedingly. According to the Midrash of
our rabbis, he will be higher than
Abraham,
who was first of all a high father and
afterwards a father of multitude. He'll
be more exalted than Moses, who was
exalted above the exalted ones of Levi,
who was a great prophet [snorts]
such that none arose like him in Israel,
who saved Israel to great salvation when
they came out of Egypt, and the report
of whom spread to all places until the
dukes of Edom were confounded before
him,
and trembling sees the mighty men of
Moab and all the inhabitants of Canaan
melted away. Now, pay attention to this.
But this one will be exalted far above
Moses, for when he gathers together our
scattered ones, gathers together our
scattered ones from the four corners of
the earth, he will be exalted in the
eyes of all the kings in the whole
world, and all of them will serve him
and will exalt him above them as Daniel
prophesied concerning him, all nations,
peoples, and tongues shall serve him.
Now, pay attention. He quoted Daniel
about the son of man and applied it to
this one.
He says as Daniel prophesied about him.
Now, watch what he says about this one.
He'll be loftier than Solomon,
whose dignity was so lofty that he is
said to have sat on the throne of the
Lord, and our rabbis say that he was
king over both the upper and the nether
world. But the king Messiah,
Melech Mashiach, in his
all-comprehending intelligence will be
loftier than Solomon. And you told me
it's Israel. Okay, but now let's keep
reading.
Exceedingly above the ministering
angels. He's even going to be higher
than the angels because that same
comprehensive intelligence will approach
God, pay attention to this, will
approach God more nearly than theirs.
For it is an exceedingly high privilege
that one whose nature is compound and
material, cuz he's human, should attain
to a grade of intelligence more nearly
divine
than that which belongs to the
incorporeal, meaning angels. And so it
is said of him that his strength is
greater than that of the ministering
angels because these have no impediment
in the exercise of their intellect,
whereas that which is compound is
continually impeded in consequence of
material element in its nature. Now,
watch. It's going to get better for you,
my friend.
Accordingly, the greater his
intelligence being such as this, he is
said to be lofty exceedingly and his
strength to be greater than the angels.
And when this servant of the Lord is
born, he will continue to be marked by
the possession of intelligence enabling
him to acquire from God what is
impossible
what is impossible for any to acquire
until he reaches the height where there
none of the sons of men, except him,
have ever ascended. No son of man has
attained the height except him
who has ascended there. From that day,
he will be counted with his people
Israel and will share their subjugation
and distress. In all their affliction,
he will be exceedingly afflicted because
of their being outcast and scattered to
the ends of the world. His grief will be
such that the color of his countenance
will be changed from that of a man, and
pain pains and sicknesses will seize
him. I'm almost done. For great grief,
as physicians know, by producing
melancholy, subjects a man to many
diseases. And all the chastisements
which come upon him in consequence of
his grief will be for our sakes. Now,
watch. And not from any deficiency or
sin on his part which might bring
punishment and strain because he is
perfect in the completeness of
perfection
as Isaiah says, truly all his pains and
sicknesses will be for us. Do you agree
with the Rabbi?
No, I mean not necessarily. I disagree.
Can
>> That's fine. And I You're free to
disagree.
>> the reason I do now the reason why the
Rabbi would necessarily say this is that
he is in there there are groups of
people, right? Who do believe that as
they know that the
you know 52 and 53, right? Essentially
believe, right? That this actually does
refer to the Messiah. That 52 and 53 do
not So you do admit there are Rabbis who
believe that, right?
What? You do believe there are Rabbis
who do believe it's about Messiah.
Well, of course. However, this isn't
necessarily once again this is not
necessarily saying that he is you know
directly that doesn't say that he is
close to God, of course. It's comparing
you know, it's essentially saying that
he has you know some sovereignty, right?
No, it doesn't say some sovereignty. Can
I can I read what he said again? I'm
going to read one more time.
>> Sure. But the king Messiah in his all
comprehending intelligence will be
loftier than Solomon because let me read
on. I'm not going to read all of it,
it's too long. He will continue to be
marked by the possession of intelligence
enabling him to acquire from God what is
impossible
for any to acquire until he reaches that
height where there none of the sins of
men except him have ever ascended. Do
you understand that this Rabbi is
shocked by this passage because he
doesn't want to admit that this means
the Messiah is basically God's equal
because like you he can't believe
someone human can be so divine, but he's
forced by the language to say what he
said because that's how clear Isaiah
52:13 is that he's now struggling with
it and doesn't know what to do with it?
Well, and the
the thing is is that with you know with
you know with Rabbi you know Crispin the
thing is, right?
Is that it doesn't necessarily say
divine. It says that he received his
knowledge. And the reason why I still
wouldn't believe it's Christ regardless
if that is the case where he says even
if he is receiving
you know the level of knowledge, right?
You know on all you know sort of you
know all knowingness, right? Or an
exaggerated all knowingness it could be
exaggerated. I'd have to be into it. I'd
have to be people from the
contemporaries of Crispin who are
students of Crispin.
>> You can read it. Can I just speak
quickly?
>> Robert, wait. I do want to make a point.
Um
it still wouldn't necessarily be Jesus
and I do want to explain
>> No, I'm not saying Jesus. No, that
wasn't my This is from you're attacking
Stahli. I never said Jesus. I'm going to
repeat what I said, but let me read you
say it didn't say he's divine. Let me
read that part again because I think it
wasn't clear.
For it is an exceedingly high privilege
that one whose nature is compound,
meaning human and material, should
attain to a grade of intelligence more
nearly divine than that which belongs to
the incorporeal, meaning he's more
divine than even angels.
I Did you hear that? It's nearly Okay,
but because you didn't hear what I said,
right? I said the Rabbi like you doesn't
believe that a human being can be divine
and equal to God, but he sees the
language is so clear he doesn't know
what to do with it. Which part wasn't
clear that I said that?
But at least he's honest. He's
struggling with the text. You're just
trying to brush it aside.
You're just trying to brush it aside.
He's honest. He's saying, "Man, this
passage is a nightmare because Messiah
is just a man, but man what Isaiah said
about him cannot be said of any man. It
makes him more divine than angels and
that his
intelligence is all comprehensive
and so it makes him greater than angels,
close to God." He's struggling with the
text because he sees what it says, but
like you in response to Christianity,
you can't admit that the Messiah is God
in the flesh because then you're going
to say to the Christians, "You know
what, Christians? We have no grounds to
condemn you because the Messiah even in
our scripture is God in the flesh, equal
to God. So, why are we objecting to your
belief in Jesus as the God man?" But
because of your stubbornness and refusal
to admit Christianity is thoroughly
Jewish and faithful to the Tanakh and
its proper interpretation, you got to
deny it.
No. No, okay. So can I repeat my
question so we can end it because where
is my question? I know you're saying
that I'm being stubborn, right?
>> No, no, forget the stubborn.
I want this question. In light of what I
just read, in light of what I read, I'm
not saying believe Jesus is Messiah.
That's up to you and God.
Let me repeat my question again. Here's
my question one more time.
In light of Isaiah 52 and its language,
do you now see that Christians have a
point in saying Jesus who is an
Israelite because you said it's about
the nation Israel has been exalted to
the status
>> that Jesus was not an Israelite. That
was never denied.
>> that's You're not Let me finish my
question.
As an Israelite that Jesus Jesus
has been exalted to the status of God
which does not contradict the Tanakh
because in the Tanakh it says Israel,
the servant because you believe it's a
nation, will be exalted to that status.
And since Jesus is an Israelite, he's
already been exalted to that status. Can
you at least admit that though you don't
believe in Jesus, we're not going
against the Tanakh in believing that?
No, I I still disagree that you still go
against the Tanakh in the belief.
[clears throat]
However, and can I explain why?
>> Go ahead. Explain it and then you can
get last word and we'll be done. Go
ahead.
Okay. So, the reason why is because the
fact that it's it's still contradictory
to the nature of Jesus and the reason
why is because the fact that Jesus Jesus
is supposed to be God, right? Meaning
he's supposed to have a divine essence
which is also eternal.
So, it confuses me when I hear, right?
That God is giving something to God.
You sure about that? You sure you want
to go there now?
>> Yes, if he's giving Oh, wait, wait,
wait, wait. I'm giving you a chance
because you're going to embarrass
yourself.
Go to Psalm 82:8.
You'll see. Wait, going to stop. Okay.
You'll see you really don't know your
Tanakh because I want everyone to hear.
Let me repeat what you said. It confuses
you how God can give something to God.
You just proved then the God of Judaism
is not God because in Psalm 82:8 it
says, "Arise oh Elohim
Okay, but hold on. Let me finish. Arise
oh Elohim
and do what?
You inherit all the nations. He'll do
what?
>> He'll judge judge the earth and you
inherit all the nations. How can God
inherit anything? He already possesses
the nations. You see your logic?
Mhm. However, and now here's the
>> the however. Okay.
Yosef, can we do this? Let's just call
it a night, man. We're going to have to
agree to disagree because you just said
I want you to This is going to sink in
by the Ruach Hakodesh. He's going to now
He's going to haunt your conscience to
see your Tanakh doesn't agree with your
Judaism because you said, "How can God
give something to God?" So, I'm going to
return the favor. I'm an atheist now.
Forget I'm a Christian.
I'm the atheist. Mr. Jew, how can your
God inherit the nations? How can inherit
anything from anyone if he's God? See, I
can play that game with you, my friend.
But let's now put it to bed. But go
ahead, finish your point.
All right. Well, about Psalm [snorts]
he Psalms actually have to go in two
minutes, but I will finish this point on
Psalm 82, right? As we say, the thing is
right here, right? It says, you know,
see you see how you know right the word
is you know you will inherit all the
nations.
>> Yes. The thing is this is not
necessarily God receiving something new.
If you're going to read this in a
literal way
you know I'll see not face value with
you know a concept you know so the
scripture hold on the concept of versus
you know our scripture then yes you're
going to basically believe that this
means that God is now inheriting
something new. But the reason why it
says you know you are inheriting all the
nations is literally because all the
nations belong to him. Not that he is
receiving something new. Not that
something is Oh,
Yosef, wait. So, God can inherit
something that already belongs to him,
but Jesus cannot be given something that
already belongs to him and it proves
he's not God. Do you see your hypocrisy?
No, because here's the thing. Jesus has
now has now created essence. That's the
thing. Okay, but you changed the
argument. Let me repeat your argument.
We're going to have to end it because
you see you keep going all over the
place. Your initial argument is how can
God give to God anything? That was your
argument. Did you remember that
argument?
Yes. However, Okay, but now do you admit
that's a bad argument because God can be
given something that already possesses
because that's what you just said about
Psalm 82:8.
Thank you, Yosef. We'll talk in the
future. I mean I'll give you that. I'll
give you that. You'll give me that? Say
it again.
I'll give you that. That's fair. Okay,
good. So, God willing I'll contact you
soon. You're a respectful guy, but stop
help helping Muslims to bash Christians.
It's not going to go both well for you.
So, God willing I'll talk to you soon,
all right? Baruch Hashem.
Mhm. Baruch Hashem. Hold on before you
go. Okay, good. I do want to say I
cannot promise you that I won't go back
on NSC and I'll tell you why.
I have to look into the claims you made,
okay? Can I believe everything about NSC
specifically? I cannot believe
everything I hear at face value,
you know?
And then and then I'll look into the
things that these claims here as well
and then I will either write something
and I'll speak to you later.
>> write what you want, man.
We've been writing for 2,000 years back
and forth. Anyone can write anything.
It's not what you can write, it's what
you can prove because you make
assertions. It doesn't mean I'm not
interested in assertions. I want
exegetical proof. And if you're honest
to God, let me be honest and up front.
If you're honest to God, this is
irrefutable. You can't refute it if
you're honest. But if you're going to
tap dance like Muslims do yeah, you can
say anything you want, get away with it
and it'll satisfy you. To each his own
because I can't convince you and I'm not
your judge.
All right, fine. All right, buddy.
All right.
Take care, buddy.
Bye-bye. Shalom.